welcome to star trek your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
so yesterday i put the trailer up for
ghostbusters afterlife and i did that
because this film more than any really
that are coming out in the next six
months i am most excited by
and the trailer does not let us down if
this film is half as good as it looks it
might actually be a worthy successor to
the original an original movie that for
me is one of the very few films in
history that is actually perfect
perfect writing perfect performances
perfect casting it is
a very rare thing in cinematography that
there is nothing i would change about it
now
i even went as far as saying in one of
my comments but that maybe this film
could make up for the last ghostbusters
attempt
but we'll talk about a little bit more
in a second but what do we get from the
trailer well there's one thing that i'm
intrigued by i have a little bit of a
theory
we know that bill murray is going to
make a cameo in this film we also know
that dan aykroyd is coming back as ray
but we know that dan aykroyd from a
previous trailer is in his occult shop
they call him he answers the phone he's
in the shop that we see in ghostbusters
2 but we don't know anything about where
venkman is
but in the start of this movie there is
some unusual character
he's driving his car it turns over into
a cornfield he's he's got a ghostbusters
trap we see him carrying into a home we
see some sort of ghost following him a
poltergeist following him stalking him
honestly i have no idea
[Music]
we then see him put the trap into the
hall in the living room and then
spengler's granddaughter find it
some years later potentially
we know that bill murray has made a
cameo and that a lot of people have said
that his performance is stunning
would it make sense so that actually he
doesn't really appear in the film but he
is the strange character at the
beginning of the film that he knows
something is happening he is there
trying to help spengler or
he is involved in whatever's going on
with spengler and that that is who we
see at the start of the film it's
venkman that is hiding the trap
i found this in my living room
wait a minute
this thing is real
to be honest i think that would be
absolutely brilliant and a really really
lovely way of having bill murray in this
movie
so much better than the cameos they had
for the other ghostbusters film and just
a really nice nod to the characters and
then i want to see rey
in the movie i want to see him more than
just given advice i want to see him get
involved if possible
because they are the ghostbusters
their involvement in this film is
absolutely vital for its success but
only in small parts i don't want to see
them in massive parts of the movie
because it really has got to focus on
the next generation and that's what this
film should be about it's about bringing
the ghostbusters into an entirely new
situation and entirely new characters i
was i was really worried about there
being kids and i was thinking oh for
god's sake they've done a movie with
kids that's almost as bad as what they
did in the last one
what do we do
i love this car
go go
but actually the more i see the film for
the less concerned i am
and the more convinced i am that they
have really managed to do something
beautiful and jason reitman as the
director is the perfect choice he
respects the original film so much he
seems to have changed almost nothing
one good example of that are the special
effects the special effects of the dogs
you can see from the trailer that don't
get me wrong they're pretty good
[Music]
and the cgi is actually capable of
producing something more realistic than
that but they've respected the original
effects the dogs kind of look like they
did from the original film and i love
that and even more than that remembering
from the first movie when the trap gets
shut down and the ghost energy explodes
to the top and then spreads through the
city they've recreated that for the new
film it looks almost exactly the same
[Music]
what exactly is happening here
we need to finish what our grandfather
started
that's not good
they could have created special effects
far more advanced than that but they
haven't they've kept it
honest to the original
ecto one they haven't messed with it
they've it genuinely looks like it's 30
years old
it's just
beautifully put together and i'm really
looking forward to it
but can it make up for
the last ghostbusters film and what do i
really think about the last ghostbusters
film
well it's universally hated
now i don't care about this thing about
films being woke i don't care about
transgender characters i don't really
care about characters that are
traditionally men being turned into
women look at what they did with
battlestar galactica everybody went
crazy when starbuck was cast as a female
even starbuck himself
the original act went crazy
but then he learned to respect that
benedict actually apologized and
actually then appeared with the new
starbuck character herself
they had an idea for that character
turned into a woman actually was
relevant to the story and it my god it
worked now anything like that
if it's relevant to the story and it
works for the story and pushes the story
forward i don't care if they mess with
things like that i do care though if
they do it with an agenda in mind and
that seems to be what they did with the
last ghostbusters film yes the
ghostbusters were women oh my god did
they spend a lot of the movie telling
you that repeatedly they sort of went
why can't the ghostbusters be women and
then made an entire movie ramming it
down her throat but for me there's a
worse crime
the comedy in the original ghostbusters
film is actually quite subtle it's
sarcasm there's no real slaptic humor
it's it's them acting like idiots at
times yeah but it's not in your face
it's hilarious don't get me wrong but
it's subtle it's quite a subtle humor
they didn't do that in the female
ghostbusters movie
like the
female agenda they tried to ram the
comedy down our throats as well and it
didn't work it wasn't funny
it just
was a bad film and it actually didn't
even make that much sense as a movie so
no from beginning to end terrible film
if this new movie ghostbusters afterlife
is even half as good as it looks
and i think it might actually be better
because i think they're holding a lot
back
then this is not going to just be a
worthy successor to the ghostbusters
film because don't get me wrong this
isn't a reboot this is a sequel this is
ghostbusters part three
i honestly think it is modernized the
franchise brought it to a whole new
generation of people a whole new
generation of kids that are going to
immediately go back and love the
original movie just as much as we do
it's really really a worthy successor
and i cannot wait to see it if
you're watching disney or you're
watching any of the big companies amazon
netflix and you're considering doing
some sort of reboot
or bringing an old franchise back
watch this movie respect the original
content
don't try and change everything just for
the sake of changing it
because movie fans will not forgive you
if you [ __ ] it up
so
disney amazon take note
it looks like this is how you do it so
thanks for watching if you are new to
the channel please like subscribe hit
that bell notification share the video
wherever the hell you like
i really appreciate it and i will see
you next time
long what kind of scientist was grandpa
honestly i have no idea
[Music]
i found this in my living room
wait a minute
[Music]
this thing is real
somehow a town that has no fault lines
is shaking on a daily basis
what is that
maybe it's the apocalypse
oh my god
this isn't a mine it's a gateway
[Applause]
what do we do
i love this car
go go
what exactly is happening here
we need to finish what our grandfather
started
that's not good
[Music]
[Music]